[موسيقى]
خيار خبيل بحر واد سلسله طويله من الشطان
الرمليه والجزر الصغيره التي تتغير
تضاريسها بسبب عوامل المد والجزر
هذه المنطقه تقاعد ضمن الحدود الهولنديه
جنوب شرق بحر الشمال ودرجه اليونسكو عام
2009 على لائحه التراث العالمي كما انها
في فصل الشتاء تعتبر موطنا لتكاثر نحو 12
مليون طائر سنويا
هنا جزيره فليلاند او صحراء الشمال اصغر
جزر الارخبيل واكثرها بريه يعيش على ارضها
نحو الف شخص على مدار العام وهي مقصد مفضل
لمحبي الاستمتاع بالطبيعه
البحار واحد من الاشخاص المقيمين في
الجزيره تتمحور حياته هنا حول التقاط
المحاري وجمعه وتقديمه كاطباق لذيذه
للسياح
لقد عشت هنا طوال حياتي وعائلتي ايضا
ابحرت لاكثر من 35 عاما في جميع بحار
العالم لكنني العام الماضي قررت التوقف
لافتح كوخ المحار الصغير الخاص بي في
الجزيره احب حقا العيش هنا خاصه في فصل
الشتاء انه مكان هادئ جدا كما احب قضاء
الوقت في الطبيعه وعلى الشاطئ
عند انخفاض المد تظهر للعلن مستوطنه ضخمه
من المحار كل ما عليك فعله هو الانحناء
لالتقاط افضلها
تربيه المحارف هذا المكان تعود لخمسه عشر
عاما او عشرين بالمجمل يمكن ان يكون هناك
30 مليون طن من المحار في بحر وادم
السياح هنا متحمسون لتذوق طعم المحار الذي
يقوم غريت باعداده لهم وهو مصدر رزقه على
هذه الجزيره
شواطئ فليلان تمتد على مرمى البصر ومع
شروق الشمس يستطيع السكان والزائرون
الاستمتاع بهدوء المكان والانصات لزقزقه
العصافير والطيور
هذه الشواطئ الطويله التي تمتد لنحو 20
كيلومترا اجبرت السكان على استحداث شبكه
نقل لخدمه الزائرين
اشترينا هذه الشاحنه العسكريه القديمه
وغيرناها بالكامل لتصبح وسيله لنقل
السائحين الى شواطئ وهناك كان شق طريقنا
الى نهايه الجزيره حيث يوجد ماوى صغير
والهناك سنتوجه
عبر مساحات شاسعه من الرمال تغطي نصف
الجزيره تقريبا يصل الزائرون الى ما يشبه
الكوخ الصغير وهو بمثابه متحف للجزيره
حولنا هذا المنزل الى متحف محتفظ فيه بكل
الاشياء التي التقطناها من على الشاطئ
ستجد كل شيء فغالبا ما تفقد سفن الحاويات
حمورتها ومن الممكن ان تجد القهوه او
السجائر او اي شيء اخر انت لا تعرف ابدا
ما ستجده لكننا نكتشف اشياء جديده كل يوم
هنا ايضا مهرجانات موسيقيه يقصدها الشباب
للاستمتاع بالحفلات الترفيهيه التي تستمر
لايام في احضان الطبيعه الرمليه الممزوجه
برائحه البحر